j'ai décidé de faire un truc sérieux ce
soir on va faire une interview 7 sur 7
cette source m
et bouge pas dans la jungle
ah merde on bouge pas afin la bouger
c'est cette chaîne il a bougé un peu
mais aussi peur on rallume orphée pour
pillage didier
mais les bonnes habitudes ne sont pas
perdues je vois alors donc on est à 7
sur 7 il imaginait génial j'ai toujours
voulu faire ça j'avais invité 25 mai
alors anne sinclair donc le pull mohair
un gros stylo là alors là je suis là je
suis anne sinclair les lentilles les
lentilles bleues est alors alors
d'abord on parle un peu de laque tu de
l'été en laisse ta appoint à saint
tropez
j'ai l'impression que l'était le rêve de
toutes les stars cd s'allonger sur une
blonde sur un hors bord à saint tropez
qui a pas que y'a pas que maggie arthur
il ya aussi jack nicholson il ya bruce
willis tout le monde le fait alors vous
vous réagissez comme en face à ces
images finalement où il semble que le
nec plus ultra de la vie d'une vedette
c'est d'aller s'allonger sur une blonde
sur un hors bord de la rade de saint
tropez
bah je sais pas si c'est pour que les
blondes elles ont des anneaux sera une
des grandes annonces pour passer les
jambes avec c'est ce qu'elle dit la
jambe gauche et les endroits qu'ils
grondent s'est pas vu de l'étude les
vacances et qui sait ce qui est dit et
ce qui est dit une blonde qui voit une
crotte de chien sur le trop grâce à un
remède devant elle mes emmerdes j'ai
encore glissé
les accords qu'elle est alors j'adore ce
n'est qu'une blonde s'est servie de
l'ordinateur na li et du correcteur sur
l'écran non mais aller s'allonger sur
une bourde à saint tropez et de moi j'y
suis allé parce que je jouais ramatuelle
et tous et c'est drôle un rythme non
mais c'est un espèce de rite faut y
aller faut vraiment après faut prendre
huit jours pour se reposer parce que toi
on dort pas beaucoup la balle deux c'est
quand même ça d'hommes et gamer et c'est
vrai c'est étonnant tu vas dans les
vignes à la laddh et lâcher de [ __ ]
gêne à plat c'est incroyable dans les
boîtes c'est un infernal que celle ci
les pros au raccroc t'as même pas
indemme sont ces différences ou riche tu
le payes leur caresse le ventre en
sourient les actus la remonte chez le
bord j'ai quand même les joueurs de
l'usm plan clair donc 2 million de
jeunes autour du pape au moment où le
sous marin russe et schultz échoue au
fond de la mer de barents est ce que
finalement c'est pas un retournement
l'histoire absolument incroyable je me
souviens de staline dix ans quand on lui
parlait du pape le pape combien de
divisions
est-ce que c'est pas un retournement
incroyable ça ben moi je pense pas que
ce soir autour de moi je pense que les
les jeunes de plus en plus on se tourne
de plus en plus vers vers dieu quoi
quand le veuille ou non il ya de moins
en moins de boulot on a de plus en plus
de temps il faudra bien qu'on sache un
jour un peu ce qu'on est venu ébranler
sur la terre c'est peut-être pas
forcément se lever le matin l'ébauché du
lundi au vendredi et puis le week end
les au camping de melun où
au royal de deauville selon ses moyens
mais qu'il ya surtout certainement autre
chose et je crois qu'en se tourne
inéluctablement vers vers lé par la
spiritualité mais vers le fait qu' on se
rend compte que
la quête suprême de tout individu c'est
de se fondre avec le dieu qui est dans
notre coeur et que c'est là que se
trouve la solution
je pense vraiment que ça va être même de
plus en plus marqués quoi s'intéresser
de plus en plus à dieu j'en suis sûr à
la bonne heure juste dieu si tu nous
regardes je suis comme bricaire si tu
nous regardes bon alors les fleurs il
nous regarde a annoncé le mec d'entrevue
quand donc
autre sujet de l'été le concorde alors
c'est un petit morceau de ferraille qui
a fait éclater le connais je sais pas si
vous le savez jean marie mais la piste
n'avait pas été examinée à cause des
pompiers qui devaient répéter un
sauvetage et on n'avait pas et alors est
ce que c'est un chat des jeunes que des
gaza sauf c'est mon skate du camion toi
on se dit alors à cause des pompiers qui
m'a chasse il avait des quais avec des
si on pourrait y faire ce qui est sûr
c'est que il ya des gens qu'on peut
encore pour faire paris gonesse ce
qu'était à l'onu elle c'est encore pire
ce qui était dans l'hôtel sur lequel est
tombé le concorde parce que oui aussi
toutes les toutes les blagues évidemment
qui s'enchaînent
1 la différence entre le crillon et
genève non c'est que le crillon
et sur la place de la concorde est
encore dit les la place les de l'hôtel
c'est parce qu'il ya eu des morts il ya
eu des morts c'est pas drôle parce qu'il
ya eu des morts c'est sûr et certain
donc les blacks ça on ne peut pas les
empêcher de courir réputés comme lady
diana human elle était morte
en revanche pour dire que quand on meurt
en paquets d'un paquet sans qui meurt
dans un avion qui coûte très cher c'est
vrai qu'on en parle évidemment
énormément c'est ce que je voulais à
l'honneur des oyats il ya via à peu près
8000 morts sur les routes par an / 50 de
santé 8000 par 50 par 52 devait jouer
avec la jeunesse affaiblissant sa prison
cinq ans s'est fait plus de 150 morts
par semaine sur les routes meilleur dans
l'anonymat le plus total donc à un
concorde ce week-end en gros quoi oui
rien concorde tous les week-ends et donc
la voilà c'est après qu'ils allaient
faire une belle croisière est au sahara
était un peu plus vite que prévu quoi
l'histoire de la corse donc on va
recevoir le prince napoléon donc
m'échappe a bougé l'armée dia un prince
c'est un petit peu au cycle obligé donc
il va devenir tout à l'heure les accords
de matignon dont on a beaucoup parlé cet
été est ce que pour vous après la
bretagne fait la bretagne fait l'alsace
est le pays basque le savoy c'est là
c'est la fin de la france à 10 location
de la france où est-ce qu'au contraire
finalement c'est comme les pays
étrangers où les codes plus ou moins
dépendantes et et la catalogne en
espagne à il ya deux et gassi qu il ya
une petite minorité de mai quand une
énorme paire de couilles qui prennent la
vie qui tue et qui [ __ ] les jetons à
tout le monde qu'ils ferment donc leur
gueule et
et ça c'est terrible pour le pour la
corse alors moi mon mon point de vu
ainsi j'étais en face de 2,5 hier ben je
dirais que je préfèrerais avoir le point
de vue qui avait que chevènement
ouais c'est à dire de dire bah c'est un
département comme les autres et puis ça
suffit comme ça qu est-ce que sinon tout
le monde va demander son ami ennemi
d'entraînement même chemin et pilar
jospin il a joué petit bras qu fait un
peu petite [ __ ] quoi parce que c'est pas
bien non c'est m c'était mieux de rester
ferme
ce qui me fait d'ailleurs un petit peu
marre et c'est que il ce don qui lui
donne la mort vraiment pour lui
demandant plus le commandement d'al le
pardon pour le tout les mêmes les crimes
de sang mais mérignac ouais c'est
pourquoi pas quoi je veux dire que oui
il a buté mais il est quand j'ai même vu
que les corses demandait que les mecs
pour les prisons qu'ils soient plutôt
plutôt encore ce soit plutôt ensemble et
enfin ils sont barreaux si possible je
serai mieux prisonniers dans l'île avec
la plage comme limite toile que la plage
est bien un peu dans logos beignets
plutôt partisan de la fermeté le
troisième départ de chaque mode normal
normal d'accord la république je serais
parti du partisan de normal d'ailleurs
fait remarquer oui que ce qui est assez
comique chez les grosses couilles corse
c'est que cathy il se dégonfle entre eux
et que tu y en a qui arrivent en haut de
la pyramide donc c'est son tour de chair
dégueu mais il appelle au calme un peu
il en voie d'être freiné un peu
maintenant parce que le prochain c'est
moins tu as donc un titre assez leur
tour il ya un petit moment de calme
édition pourrait peut-être quand même
rené que changer de zimmer ouais il se
bute à tout va et c'est pas bien on n'a
pas le droit de s'entretuer on n'a pas
le droit de deux mois le prix du pétrole
ça vous inquiète tout le monde dans la
rue
je jouais en mai pour une fois
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure là il a l'air
décidé à serrer la vis de ces lots ils
ont décidé c'est les pays 2
c'est le peuple qui a décidé d'augmenter
le prix du baril va se faire plus de
blake huawei c'est tout normal baho
marque faut les comprendre on leur a dit
qu'on leur avait dit en 73 vous pourrez
purent faire un coup comme ça mais dans
10 ou 15 ans parce qu'on a retrouvé
d'autres énergies machabee s'aperçoivent
que non finalement l'essence en utilise
quand même toujours c'est quand même
toujours on en utilise 10 on va
l'augmenter de 40% puis ça va nous faire
un peu plus dernier sujet de l'été jean
marie bigard donc dans votre interview 7
sur 7 la folle passion de lara fabian
pour sébastien le chanteur d'ali baba
j'étais pas jeudi soir
non non je t'ai beaubourg ne savait pas
on n'a pas une cassette on a cessé fini
avec patrick fiori et ça s'est mis en
marche avec sébastien le chanteur d'ali
baba
d'accord vous n'étiez pas au courant non
je suis au courant on va aller
et voilà j'accueille maintenant une
copie